Hello and welcome to the video.
In this video, we will be taking a look at managing your scanning resources in Burp Suite
Enterprise Edition on a Kubernetes deployment.
In theory, Kubernetes enables Burp Suite Enterprise Edition to scale to any size.
However, the size is limited by the number of concurrent scans that your license covers.
The scanning resources page allows you to do the following.
Set a limit on the number of concurrent scans you want to run, view any active scanning resources
and associated scans, or suspend scanning altogether.
To control the amount of cloud resources that can potentially be dedicated to scanning at
any one time, set a lower concurrent scan limit.
From the settings menu, select Scan Resources.
Enable scanning should be selected by default.
Select Set a Concurrent Scan Limit and enter the maximum number of concurrent scans that
you want Burp Suite Enterprise Edition to run.
Now click Save.
These changes won't affect any scans that are currently running.
From the Scan Resources page, you can also see a list of active scan jobs.
These are the scanning resources that are currently in use.
To view details about the scan, you can click View Scan.
There may be times where you need to temporarily disable scanning.
For example, when updating Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
To disable scanning, deselect Enable Scanning.
When scanning is disabled, no new scans will be started.
Scans that are in progress will continue until they are finished.
You can change the number of concurrent scans that your license covers at any time.
This can be done via your portswiger.net account on the My Account page.
Once you have uploaded your updated license in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, this will increase
your scan limit automatically unless you have manually set a scan limit.
If you have set a concurrent scan limit, you will need to increase this manually.
If you decrease the number of scans covered by your license, then the system finishes any
scans that are already in progress, even if this exceeds your new limit.